my fear is is is not about you know
the the united states potentially
invading you know another country
although i mean i'm always worried about
sending our troops into harm's way for a
number of different reasons and the
potential foreign policy implications
that come along with that
i i am very very worried uh about the
ccp the chinese communist party
definitely i'm very very taiwan if they
go in on taiwan i mean what's america
going to do well
joe biden will do nothing i said you
know
if you end up seeing a biden presidency
you mark my words i think
and this is this is just what i know of
china and how they operate and i've been
watching them for the last 10 years of
my life
i think you'll see china go quiet and
then i think you'll see them invade
taiwan
and then you're gonna that'll be one of
them soon yes and so
but look the the chinese communist party
has infiltrated every level of our
government
and that is not sean parnell on tim
poole in a conspiracy theory
this is what a chinese professor said at
a chinese
presentation said that we've got people
at every level of the chinese communist
party he even brought up paying hunter
biden in the biden family
a couple weeks later you have eric
swalwell come out with with fang fang
being compromised by a chinese spy
you had a chinese spy driving around
dianne feinstein for 20 years now get
this and
no one no one's talked about this i'm
going to talk about it on your show for
the
for the first time a high-level chinese
diplomat
met with the allegheny county executive
rich fitzgerald in august of 2019
why is a high-level chinese official
communist party official meeting with a
county executive you know how i found
that information
on the on the chinese communist party
new york city consulate website
where they said that in this meeting oh
rich fitzgerald the allegheny county
executive welcomed us with open arms
we said that wuhan in pittsburgh our
sister cities
and we stand in august of 2019 three
months before pandemic wuhan and
pittsburgh are sister cities
what gives an allegheny county executive
the authority to make a declaration like
that number one
number two how is it okay for a county
executive and local democratic officials
to meet with a senior a high-level
chinese diplomat
to sub to subvert and by the way this is
on the ccp's
website to subvert the president's
trade policy in china and foreign policy
in china and stand steadfast in our
friendship
did you see this uh the story that came
out uh just about a week ago
data leak exposes details of two million
chinese communist party members i saw
that
the us and the uk have been infiltrated
by members of the communist chinese
party some of these biggest companies
someone working for some of these major
pharmaceutical companies so i have to
wonder when i see something like that
when i see uh fangfeng you know eric
swalwell
allegedly was having relations with this
woman and she helped fundraise for his
campaign
my question is why hasn't he resigned
already why is he on the intel committee
why isn't he under investigation having
every single communication ripped apart
and gone through the fine-tooth comb
and then when i see stories about this
guy fitzgerald you're mentioning now in
allegheny county
oh it's it's you notice this because
this is your county
right yeah it's part of my district you
you you're this is your
you know where you're this is my first
foray into politics you know i'm a war
fighter so i'm just starting to notice
this stuff but
think about this think about how many
other counties how many others
and then i wonder you say what gives him
the authority why does he do it
man i wonder if all it takes is some
hacker a chinese communist
party member who you know hacks into his
account finds his uh naughty folder and
then blackmails him with it
they have a meeting and they say oh take
a look at this image well look that's
that's part of their playbook
but china knows our china knows the game
the chinese communist party
does not want for resources part of what
they do part of right out of the chinese
communist party playbook
is putting pressure on local state and
federal officials that they think
that they can get in with and it just so
happens i mean
look this is a republican and democrat
problem now i don't think that
i mean you've got dianne feinstein and
eric swalwell and then
you've got i i i i technically agree but
i actually kind of disagree with
you saying it's a republican democrat
problem it's bad for all of us it's bad
for all of us as well
i'm not sure the democrats care well i
mean look if the democrats cared eric
swalwell would not be on the
intelligence committee
um if if the democrats joe biden would
not be president-elect or
will be on january 6 or about to be
i mean look this is a this is a problem
this is this is a
problem that that that deserves the
attention
of every power broker in this country in
the private sector
and every head of every government
agency needs to be focused on this now
too many too many people
are in on the take man look look look it
is not hyperbolic to say
that uh joe biden is likely compromised
by communist chinese interests
he flew his son on government property
air force on air force two
to china for a 1.5 billion dollar equity
deal now i thought didn't happen i
thought the equity deal fell through but
we had china uncensored on the show and
they said
no actually it did go through just not
the way people think the negotiations
were good it worked
they got a five million dollar interest
rate interest-free forgivable loan
joe biden flew his son to china for a
private
deal joe biden's involved of course he's
the big guy
he's the big one even even outside of
accusations right from these emails so
we have leaked emails
we well they're not leaked emails we
have the laptop was the emails were
published
we have confirmation from tony bob
yalinski who worked on some of these
deals
get rid of all that stuff just say just
say you know what okay to the you're
arguing with your democrat buddies say
forget it all
it is not in dispute that joe biden took
air force 2
to fly his son to china for private
equity deals
joe biden used government resources to
enrich his family
that is a fact not in dispute by anybody
and now this guy's on track to become
president look it's concerning
and i would say about you know allegheny
county executives local
local county executives it's not
uncommon for them to meet with diplomats
and welcome them to their cities but i
would say
why are you meeting with our number one
geopolitical foe
probably the greatest human rights
abuser on the planet they put
people in concentration camps their
number one
goal is to become the lone superpower
overtaking the united states of america
does this not deserve questions from
maybe for somebody in the middle east i
used to always be like why were they so
nice to the nazis in 1930 why was hitler
man of the year why did
germany yeah why did they host the
olympics why was germany such the love
child of the world
in the early days when maybe their human
rights abuses weren't public knowledge
yet
peace i think it was yeah who said that
neville chamberlain
neville chamberlain said that so after
he's michael who brought that up on the
show right
yeah the saying peace in our time was
when neville chamberlain talked to
hitler
and they were like he comes back and
goes don't worry he says he won't attack
us yeah they gave him
and they did a piece of czechoslovakia
or something i don't know neville
chamberlain gave him a big piece of land
it was like he's not going to do any
he's not going to invade any more guys
the su dayton land i don't remember yeah
the idea the idea
that china is our friend that is being
you're hearing this
in the news from many in the democrat
party is
one of the greatest fallacies of our
time they are not our friend
they they do not want to be they want to
overtake our country they do not want to
cooperate with us
like look look it's very very very
concerning and
i'm telling you every leader in our
country needs to focus on this right now
but clearly people like swahwel either
don't care or
like it yeah i don't think he
intentionally took a spy under his wing
he'd resign if he cared
well now yeah i know and so if there was
enough of a public outcry he would
resign i don't know if it's that they
don't
care is that they're just ignorant to
the goals the foreign policy goals of
china or maybe they don't understand
well let me
let me tell you something when i worked
for some for abc news univision's joint
venture fusion i worked in the abc news
building
i worked in the univision building i
worked for vice
what people think they think that
individuals get bribed to do things
they think that like i would go to you
and say hey i want you to you know steal
ian's glasses here's 10 bucks
well that's that's not how bribes work
that's not how the media works that's
not how political manipulation works
here's how it works
if you run a company that and you want
to be a woke progressive or conservative
company
you don't hire a journalist and then say
i'll give you extra money to lie and
make fake news
you seek out those who lie and make fake
news and say want a job
and they say yes i do here's your salary
do whatever you want because i already
know what you do
eric swalwell got help with his
political career from fong fung
the chinese communist party finds
feckless ignorant
morons and then says make them win
how can we make them win why do we have
feckless ignorant morons in our
in our government because we are
government of by and for the people
that's a popularity vote because anybody
can run
so what they what they what they'll do
now is they'll exploit that system
in any legal possible way they can or
even illegal like we have a thousand
talents program these professors are
getting
huge stacks of cash from china and
they're getting arrested for because
they're legal
or they're lying to the government about
the money they're getting china's
willing to break the rules
and they're willing to do whatever it
takes to exploit our system and
this the spy work who is helping eric
swalwell get elected
is well that's that's basically the
point swalwell
probably wouldn't even be in office i
don't know maybe not maybe he would have
that's fine but either way he should
have resigned the moment the story broke
the moment he had us hit a briefing and
the fbi came in said you were propped up
by chinese spies
even if it were me i'd walk out and be
like i'm out i resign
straight up or at least take him off the
intelligence committee so that he
doesn't have access to our country's
most sensitive secrets
yeah that too yeah i mean but i don't i
don't think the democrats care
look at remember steve king remember
what happened to him when he tweeted
about white nationalism yes
he got booted off every every committee
then he lost the pre-order
primary because the republican party
said we don't want to associate with you
and what you're saying
so we want someone else that was the
republican party because the republicans
for all of their faults are still
substantially better than democrats in
many ways
i think both parties are full of crony
establishment garbage but you still have
a decent amount of people in the
republican party with you i want to do
something about it i mean obviously i'm
a republican but yes i totally agree
with you
i totally agree with you but again it's
just look at omar comes out and says all
that stuff about you know jews in israel
that was like the way the way i
described it was illinois omar was crop
dusting anti-semitism you know what crap
dusting is
the plane comes down and gets real close
to the ground but doesn't touch it
the things ill and omar said weren't
overtly anti-semitic but people were
like
you're reading into it but hold on you
said three things it's like if you said
one thing we'd be like that's weird
second time we go it's kind of weird
third time's like okay that's on purpose
right
but all that happened was nancy pelosi
said we want to condemn all bigotry
and no no penalties no censure no
punishment just we condemn bigotry have
a nice day everybody
steam king steve king tweets once and
they kick him out of the party he's gone
he loses
yeah bye-bye i know and so democrats
don't do it
and eric swawwell still sits on the
intelligence committee
even though he was compromised for years
by a chinese spy you know it's funny uh
there was a meme where they were like
chinese the chinese communist party is
sending beautiful young women
to basically like get in bed literally
with
up-and-coming stars politicians
personalities
and so now it's like if you are what did
someone say they say
if you're a two and she's a ten you
probably should you gotta ask some
questions
there's probably a spy this is probably
something's not right
um can we get swat while out of the out
of the committee impeach him
the only way he gets removed from the
committee is nancy pelosi removes him
from this
from the committee you know what man
have you seen what's going on with the
the
the force the vote thing on the
progressive left i i have seen this
although i i don't know enough about it
to discuss it in any depth i have seen
it i
read a little bit about it just today
this is why i think uh i'll tell you
another reason why i don't like the
democrats after everything we've just
explained about you know
kicking people out of the party and
booting them off you know their their uh
committees you have ocasio-cortez
and she and the progressive democrats
in the democratic party because the
republicans gained so many seats
they now have the leverage to force a
vote on basically anything they want
i think they're within five votes of the
majority right like it's like the house
is very very
i think i think the democrats have a six
or seven seat majority right now which
means if the progressives went to nancy
pelosi and said
unless you give us a floor vote on these
issues
we will not vote for you for speaker in
which case the republicans
could gain control to a certain degree
they're still the minority oh for sure
so you have jimmy dore who is he's
progressive but he's populist and i
think he's a good dude and he said
you were elected to do this do it now
they won't do it
they won't challenge nancy pelosi nancy
pelosi in her weakest position yet
wants to be wants to be reelected
speaker and they have the leverage to
say
no to her and they won't no because
look say what you will about nancy
pelosi but she's shrewd she
she's she's a ruthless politician she
knows the game she's been in washington
for a long time
she's got a lot of money she's got a lot
of money in her super pac
and she she can single-handedly funnel
millions of dollars which happened in my
race by the way
you know yeah she she funneled 1.2
million dollars
of of dark super pac money into
pa 17 against me i i would argue that it
didn't work
uh maybe maybe maybe it worked enough
but the melon voting work
no no well the mailing building worked
real well for the democrats
you know thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you